[Music]
what we try to do every so often on the
show is we try to feature a greedy rich
person and the horrible things that they
are doing
in our culture today today we're going
to pick on the greedy rich person elon
musk
elon musk says spacex starlink
satellites active over ukraine
after a request from embattled countries
leaders he's made his satellite time
available to the ukrainians uh for free
yeah
putin knocked out their internet and so
he got a direct appeal from the
president of ukraine he said sure hold
on one i'll move a satellite over there
something you can't do
unless you're elon yeah i can't move a
satellite over there you can't either
you can't move a satellite over there
but we're not greedy rich people what's
that joystick look like by the way
like somewhere at spacex somebody's got
essentially a joystick or something or
is it all computer keyboard i don't know
these are questions i have yahoo news
reporting vatilair putin's unprovoked
invasion has left parts of the country
without internet while spacex has
launched thousands of communication
satellites to bring broadband to hard to
reach areas of the world we should bring
the internet to hard to reach areas of
the world because that's what greedy
rich people do because of course we know
that those hard to reach areas of the
world those people pay a lot
and they're going to make all their
money back
no they don't have any money you doobs
okay so just in case you're wondering
but anyway
users on the ground access the broadband
signals beamed back to earth using a kit
sold by spacex uh whether you try to cut
while you try to colonize mars russia
will try to occupy the ukraine
while your rockets successfully land
from space russian rockets attack
ukrainian civil people we ask you to
provide ukraine with starlink nations
stations to address sane russians to
stand
um a
an official from ukraine tweeted this at
elon and elon did uh he moved the
satellites into place and are making
them available to the ukrainians for
free and this just happens to be
obviously one of the richest people on
the planet a very well-known brand and
obviously an extraordinary current event
but what i know about a lot of rich
people is
if the general public especially all the
snowflakes who want the rich to pay
their fair share if they had
a scintilla
of of evidence oh look at that
look up cintilla that's a small number
it is it's it's a very small number yeah
it's very
very small but if they had any clue
how those rich people give every day to
do extraordinary things for people
uh they they would they would shut their
mouths and sit down they just don't have
any clue you know why because good rich
people debate this with facts oh i know
i'm not using facts
i'm just like i use actual numbers and
research
that would be that's that's not the way
you argue things you're just supposed to
be emotional and go on twitter
isn't it funny the irony is is those are
the people if you add up what people in
north america the united states of
america private citizens give to
charitable causes
and people in need every year it dwarfs
the entire economy of most small nations
yeah
but we don't talk about that no because
rich people are evil and they should be
punished and they're not paying their
fair share that's right senator warren
is after elon musk because he didn't pay
the taxes she thought he should pay that
was a mistake because he apparently hits
back a little clap back there and wore
her butt out but um
yeah
it's true it's it's
as we say down in tennessee she bit off
more than she could chew there
so um that's a problem but uh yeah just
one more evil person doing horrible
things in the world making uh free
free uh broadband available to the
ukrainians by moving his own personal
satellite over their nation to cause it
i know not something i got up this
morning and thought i could possibly do
yeah he didn't send he didn't say that
this morning i'm gonna move the
satellite right that doesn't come these
are not conversations i'm in no he
didn't ship a bunch of food and clothes
he moved a satellite or two or three
it's extraordinary
giving the country internet apparently
something the united states of america
government couldn't figure out a way to
do it oh of course not no no no it's
impossible because i'm sure it begs the
question dave are you going to go to
space
are you am i going to go to school yeah
dude i live in space
here lola seriously this guy spacex
this is gonna be he's gonna let me go
well it's not about let you he'll he'll
take your ticket you're gonna be able to
pay for this in three to five years
it'll you know i'm just asking would you
go if it's affordable and you're looking
i'm looking i'm waiting on my credit
card to frequent flyer miles to build up
well then you're not going
that's a good one i like that
that that would be rich dave ramsey
finally gets a credit card so it could
go to space
not gonna happen
oh i don't know ken
you strike me somebody they would try
that
i just did a i just did my first um
about 18 months ago did my first
parachute i know i had done this first
time what was that like skydiving we've
actually not talked about the last it
was an absolute adrenaline what was your
fear factor
on a scale of one to ten i thought i was
gonna pee in my pants that's what i
figured i was gonna be that guy that
would be the little
and you know what i just i i never got
nervous they did such a good job
prepping us right and the company was so
professional right uh and um and they've
got these cool things that they they
hook to your parachute that if the guy
you're strapped to dies and his doesn't
come out once you reach a certain
altitude it automatically deploys your
chute all right so i'm like this is
really completely idiot-proof i mean now
we're using like four shoots involved
one of them is going to go off i think
i'm going to be okay so you went i
probably had more risk driving over
there
you know
jumping out of the airplane so i was not
by the time i got up there i was excited
but i was not now were you did you have
the instructor yeah oh that's the only
way to do it front or behind
with rookies you they have to be in uh
let's see you're in front of them
so you're looking down yeah no
obstructions we're flying you're just
looking at the earth
hurtling at you so fun very impressive
it was a blast i'm going again yeah
adrenaline rush man we got the bottom we
went to eat breakfast my hands were
shaking not because i was tired but the
adrenaline dumped i could only imagine
it was so funny oh
it's hard maybe i'll go fly with him i
think he's going to go to school right
now i'm just concerned about elon's
generosity i can't believe he's an evil
rich person of this magnitude you can
bless him out when you're on the shuttle
with him that's it you know you evil
rich people stop your generosity you're
giving evil rich people everywhere a bad
name
this is the ramsey chef